he saw what McGee had done as a
competitor to the Golden State Warriors
the previous year's James inside what a
spin see LeBron turning the corner so
effective we seen that a lot early on it
back collect early so you're in a a
little trot he needs to catch it and see
five white jerseys when he doesn't
you're in trouble if you're the Spurs
good job of pushing it finishing and
taking the hit give you other Spurs good
job of pushing it finishing and taking
the hint Cunningham on James
wide open three got it
[Applause]
this is just one guy pushing the
basketball how many times do you have to
see this movie to understand how can you
lose and if you're LeBron this is the
recipe for win to understand how can you
lose any of your LeBron this is the
recipe for winning the clock for James a
deep three
[Applause]
I'm the Stars I'm not double teaming I'm
gonna trust rudy Gay to play good
defense to contest
another deep three wow this guy is
giving the Spurs that work tonight off
the Kuzma screen got it back
[Applause]
[Music]
doesn't have it give the basketball up
move without the ball takes a little
contact knocks it down mama